كان لدى دبي خطة واضحة للغاية حول كيفية
التعامل مع هذا
كما قلت ، لقد أغلقنا عندما احتجنا إلى ذلك
، ومنذ افتتاحنا ، نتابع
البيانات ، تعمل
جميع الكيانات المختلفة في دبي
معًا بشكل وثيق للغاية للنظر
في الأرقام
إذا رأينا  الامتثال لسنا بحاجة إلى
التشديد بغض النظر عما يقوله أي شخص
إذا لم نر امتثالًا في أي جزء
من الاقتصاد ومرة أخرى ننظر إلى هذ
القطاع بعناية فائقة حسب القطاع وا
قطاع الفرعي لنرى أين نحتاج إل
ال
شديد  وأين نحتاج إلى رفع
القيود وسيستمر
ذلك ، لا علاقة له بما يخبرنا به أي شخص
آخر نظرًا لوجود خطة واضحة جدًا
في يوليو / تموز غطيت إعادة الافتتاح
ويبدو أنها محسوبة للغاية ، ولا يبدو
أنها تم قياسها في ديسمبر أو  أن
التصور العالمي
يبدو أولاً وقبل كل شيء ، أعتقد أننا بحاجة إلى
إلقاء نظرة على الأرقام الصحيحة لعدد
السياح الذين أتوا
إلى دبي ، هناك القليل من سوء الفهم
حول أننا سمعنا
أننا بدأنا في يوليو مع 40 ألف
سائح وانتهينا في ديسمبر / كانون الأول
قد يبدو عدد 560.000. 560.000 عددًا كبيرًا ولكن عندما
اعتدنا على
الترحيب بأكثر من 5 1.5 مليون زائر
في ديسمبر من كل عام ، فإن هذا يمثل
ثلث الأرقام المعتادة ،
لذلك لم تكن دبي مليئة بأي
قدر من الخيال
بالإضافة إلى  تم تعقب البروتوكولات
باستمرار
وأي شخص على
مدار أه
خلال أواخر ديسمبر
وبداية يناير تم إغلاق أكثر من 25
مؤسسة
بسبب عدم الامتثال لذلك
لم يتغير شيء مع الطريقة التي
نتعامل بها مع الأشياء بطريقة محسوبة للغاية
لكن فلسفتنا هي
أننا يجب أن نعمل من خلال هذا الوباء
ونبقى مفتوحًا ونبقي الجميع
آمنين ونتأكد من أننا نعمل عن كثب مع
الصناعة لضمان حدوث الامتثال
بطريقة موثوقة
كان لديك ارتفاع قياسي إلى ما يقرب من 4000
حالة في اليوم وهو ما
يقرب من أربعة أضعاف  ما رأيناه في تشرين الثاني (نوفمبر) ،
ما الذي أدى إلى هذا الارتفاع المفاجئ ، ثم
تبين البيانات أنه مرتبط مباشرة
بالامتثال عندما كان لدينا امتثال 98 إلى 99
لم نقم به  ترى أي ارتفاع عندما
انخفض ذلك بنسبة أربع إلى خمس نقاط مئوية
رأينا الأرقام ترتفع ، فهذا يخبرنا أن ما
نقوم به هو الصواب
الذي نحتاجه للتشديد علينا لضمان
وجود امتثال ومن ثم يمكننا الاسترخاء
مرة أخرى
حيث تقف اليوم مع التطعيمات
و  بهذه الوتيرة ،
هل تعتقد أنك ستكون مرتاحًا
بما يكفي للترحيب بالعالم هنا في
الربع الرابع من المعرض العالمي
مائة بالمائة ، نحن واثقون جدًا
تحت قيادة دولة الإمارات العربية المتحدة
مع برنامج الإطلاق الحالي مع
جميع التدابير الاحترازية المعمول بها التي
نشعر بها  واثقون تمامًا من
أننا سنكون مستعدين لذلك سنكون مستعدين لذلك ، سنكون مستعدين
للتأكد من
أن النمو يبدأ هذا الصيف
وبحلول المعرض والربع الرابع
نتطلع إلى الترحيب بالعالم